the spherical bosconia not be missed I
like i missed a throw I'm said I'm sorry
this one I have to cross out like a side
track after resurrection ever and this
one I was not going to be a very good
computer simulator here that was Ramsey
what was the original data is actually
we've got the television camera ready
too I mean we got to be other an exhibit
of a wonderfully types that table that
man we did this to show you so but
you'll see it in the notes so we don't
have to display that appendage ok so now
those okay so we got four ways to cover
this guy three in here 3 here 3 here to
here for their nothing's forest unless
we get a sub sumption which we do oh
yeah this one is subsumed enough by this
ok so now then that forces us to take
this guy also be 00 is like now this one
is also subsumed business and so this
stuff sumption rule is actually proves
those rather powerful in the small
example in a large example maybe not so
much a pro does substantially
12 losing things okay zoo 01 this
assumes 0 1 0 0 0 1 has nothing in it
but we were my girls in this guy 001
we've already chosen this guy is it as a
member of our final set of fun but up
now what do you saying 010 yeah and 001
okay this guy is a subset of that okay
then by that time that to us is taking
to left you need to take them both
because of this is the only 1i colors do
you wanna stand on the coverage week to
okay so sorry we have used only sub
sumption not great in this particular
case to show that the minimum cover
takes three takes three things not in a
larger case a substantial actually is
still viable in and but i also have a
strategy of branching if you want to
find the the absolute minimum based on a
of a cover problem then you have a
choice of branching on rose or on
columns you can find a column in which
you have which you have maybe three
choices of which row to do even so you
can branch the three ways so you can
find a row or you can say how many roads
i have to take one of these rows and so
you just choose some some some growth at
that eliminates a lots of columns and
use that use that approach to try to get
nothing out in this case we're just
looking for a heuristic in a moment are
looking for the absolute minimum and the
greedy method seems to to almost always
hit the absolute minimum on
a real world problem unless the problem
was constructed really debit Delos Lee
so so that's the idea of man's cover and
I think a raw electrical engineering and
have been using you know cover
techniques for a long time and I think
still the best discussion of the issues
of of that was in bed McCluskey's book
that he wrote about nineteen sixty very
nice examples and description of the
methods for for solving practical
minimum cover problems in a in a pretty
effective way although it's in it's in
the worst case it says it's NP hard
problem now let's see what time is it
getting a be here holy 1208 oh boy okay
what other things would you like to
discuss our remaining minutes today I've
got something to bring up then oh are
you have as they just wanted to comment
that this type of techniques are easier
to apply on a smaller than a pretty
large orders in all of that you just
don't the very first base that the
process of simply computing what faults
you have in what cases an extremely
expensive one okay so um yeah so let's
look let's take a look at the real how
does this relate to our real problem
okay end up and what I in a random
approach was is suggested isn't it I
mean suppose that you have to choose a a
row from this 65,000 rose well why not
just you know x e or something like that
you know i mean take some random inputs
to see how many covers
and I I tried that I don't have my data
here but it was pretty interesting that
after i had generated I should have
brought that with me like after I had
tried a hundred random inputs just to
see how many how many stuck at faults i
covered and i think that there were
still something like 20 left that i
hadn't covered yet after after 100 and
after i got up to 400 i think i had all
but six or something like this then I
was suspicious of those other six and I
run another case of 500 i think i still
like i had eight left and so there was
something that seemed to be hard to hard
to cover so then i kept eight so then I
kept a scorecard so I made a table of
four each gate not reach fault about how
many times after making random random
inputs how many times did that fault get
detected and I found that a great number
of the are the other frogs were were
detected about half the time that they
seem to be fairly easy to to do but
there were some of them that you know it
looked like in doing 300 or 500 random
cases I only only twice or once or
something with this particular gate be
we'd be found and so uh so I thought
it'd get some feeling for the for the
accounts in the columns by getting by
taking a statistical estimate see quite
just by random sampling you can get a
feeling for you don't know what the
exact number of X's in a column but you
you have an idea that that calm is is
which columns are arguing to cover and
so you will probably just be picked up
anyway and those that sort of prime
targets that
that are necessary so so when you're
faced with a larger matrix instead of
exact information some kind of
statistical approach suggested to me and
that's when I got suspicious for a
London gate that was never that I could
never pick up at all and okay but
suppose it looks at mini ass kissed and
like somewhere on the line I wanted to
talk also about aki the generalization
of these things is that I guess we'll
try to sneak that in on Tuesday let me
ask you this supposedly suppose we we
want to do a the greedy algorithm but
statistically what would be the mystical
analog of the greedy and you know it
stir up here here we have an exact
exact problem in but let's imagine was a
little bit larger me maybe it was 30 30
rolls and fifty column something like
that and the green yard would say choose
the role that has most X's in it after
looking for some shins and crossing
things out you know them then choo choo
the role that has the most X's in it and
then remove those columns and and apply
greed greed again that has the most
exiting the remaining their main thing
but now that would be for a small
example but what's what we have the
things so live you don't even want to
generate the whole matrix after all
65,000 x 800 is a fairly large large
computation
so really for this problem we should in
fact imagine alder that would that would
conceivably generalize to the next case
of the 16 by 16 bit multiplying so so it
would not an exhaustive approach of
actually generating the mall would work
would be completely infeasible for the
next case up but of the two to the 32 to
the 32 inputs so well how we do it at
probably do like an approximate greedy
algorithm based on statistics poverty I
would that you take it as someone who
hasn't spoken up yet today so we get
more people rich for example what do you
think if you don't want to keep the
table around you could just do it by
I'll just tried it you would have to do
something relatively greedy oh yeah well
are you that's the idea because reading
is a UK if you can't generate more than
a few at a time you have to pick the
best one of the ones you have so far
that but I also comes in brussels on d
i'm trying to attract it just to a
covering probably not because specifics
of our case and and so so generating a
few times I don't see what how they're
different from what you have well as you
would cover a certain number more well
no I I wouldn't know what the what the
role is it has the most in it but by
doing a sample I could guess at what I
know that would be good see so you
generate a few hundred and trade then
guess what yeah right so i might
generate a hundred things and say which
one of these hundred covered the most
and i choose that and then and then i
reduced the end and say you know the
next hundred which one covers the most
of the remaining of the remaining gates
that other any false and and so on and
that would be a proximate greedy
algorithm that that student is still
there's a problem of finding those
finding those hard ones and
random you if you for example it's
imagine the case of of the 16 by 16 k
suppose there are tuned to the 32 inputs
but only 10 of them ever tweak a certain
fault so then you got the chance of
finding a needle in a haystack you got
10 possibilities out of about 2 to the
32nd you're not going to find it at
random and so the kind of approach that
we were talking about last week where
where we actually look at the circuit
and propagate values forward and
backward looks like the only the only
reasonable way to to do that instead of
an exhaustive search now while you're
almost all here I wanted to mention that
that it's not too good to have people
dropping in the middle of the class all
the time so we please get your act
together next week will we might have to
resort to closing the door so that I
have to pound to get in or something
like that afterwards and and also
there's only 21 days until our art
shelves remember back to mark actually
okay but otherwise i'm very pleased with
the way the class is doing to show up on
high and kaiser
it's all for today